thanks for being here thanks for having
me yeah very nice to see you it's been a
while it has been a while what's the
definition of a while the while i'm
going to say uh what what years how many
years i'm going to say two years is a
while it depends on my relationship i
haven't seen my son in two years that's
not a while that's a long time right you
in two years that's a little while i
think you should see your son more often
my agent takes good care of him
[Laughter]
we got it all worked out uh this show
tapes a few hours before the boston red
sox game tonight i know you're a big fan
yeah well i was gonna fool the audience
uh the tv not this audience but the one
watching right now and pretend you
already i was gonna say oh okay let me
check the game here that was and i was
gonna say uh
oh a guy just stole home from first
[Laughter]
now they're putting him in a straight
jacket
these games are like too stressful it's
too stressful too much it's like a level
like it goes like okay boring okay
exciting too much too much yes yeah a
few weeks ago i went to a dodger game
they were playing the cardinals and it
was good because i didn't care who won
yes
that's the more relaxing kind of
baseball when you don't care a guy hits
a grand slam i was like oh that's nice
i think that people should do that on
purpose so that when they're watching
their real team they that they'll be
maybe that'll bring them down a little
because they're used to not caring well
i you're always to me
famously right around here you're just
right
i don't see you getting worked up about
anything
well man i've smashed windows i've like
no i haven't i
haven't yeah accidentally when you fell
asleep and leaned against one uh
but my mind it's like my mind is not
connected to my face
i get you i know what you mean yeah yeah
yeah
it's like what i'm thinking does not
necessarily uh control my facial
expressions so i can be like a nervous
wrecker i can be speeding in my head
drinking 18 coffees and but then i i've
answered the phone after riding an
exercise bike and drinking coffee and
people say that i just wake you up yeah
this is who you always are okay no i'm
just curious i know you work a lot you
you tour you you know you you're very
in demand community what do you do when
you're not working
i like to uh
read music and listen to books on tape
[Laughter]
well
i heard you were writing yeah is that
does this indicate that there's more to
come yes i didn't know what that meant
or i'm just practicing in cases more to
come later i'll have done it already
okay
what was i gonna say oh
so you can read the music different
speeds and you can't hear music
different speeds you could but it
wouldn't sound good but if you're
reading the music you control it more
than if you were listening to it
[Applause]
you just sewed some emotion what the
hell just happened
some wiring connected by it i know for a
second
for a second you actually showed emotion
your your brain got through into control
of your face you caused that i caused
that yes i can help you